2. Nhanh Hà Mítám tháng 5, công an tình đồng này thông tin về kế quả phá trình ál lớn,
với hợp cuộc cảnh sát hình sử, bộ công an, bác sử nhỏ nơi tự cầm đậu đường dưới
lửa đạo qua sản rau dịch tiền áo mơ tê xe má chiếc trên, chiếm đặt gần mấy nghiên
vì đồng của hàng chục nghiên người trên cả nước. Theo đó, các đời tự đại lập sản tin ạo không giả
chỉ thực, tông tin về lỗi nưởng sêu khủng, sế dự hệ thống đà cấp, chia thình các khu vực để giữ
sỗ hội tham gia. Bộ đầu sắc định có hơn 18% nghìn tệ khoản đăng ký,
tổng số tình bị chiếm đặt quy đổi khoảng muy nhiên tỷ đồng.
Lực lượng chức năng đại đồng và tức cơ đổi tự trụ chốt gồm, muyến khu hùng,
bùi thiện thình á, khổ lông chỉ, đình hiểu hài và thình phân hiệp.
Cơ đổi tự này thư et lập chính viên viên viên phân mềm viên áo,
tổ chức đạo tạo nhóm lý đường, khoảng 3 trên mạng sã hội và tổ chức sự kiện lôi kéo nhà đầu tư.
Tòa mộ số tình vời trơi nộ vào được chuyển về các vi cà nhân,
dùng vào buộc định tiêu sài đầu tư bất động sản.
Hẹn chứ nạn đang được vở giọt đưa trạc.
Công ăn tình đồng này, khiến cáo người dân đơn cao,
phản giác trước các nạn hình đầu tư tình áo hông số hùng quân gốc,
để tránh bị lợi dụng, chiếm đặt tại sản.